let me tell you let me tell you what i
saw the other day i saw i saw this story
i'm like oh tyler check this out to see
if this story is true or not so this kid
17 year old kid i don't know if you
heard about this or not the 17th oh my
god this story is suing his parents for
being born white did you hear about this
i didn't hear about it so let's talk
about i don't know how old this story is
though but but still like but but here's
the concept of his rejection but here's
the point this is becoming more and more
i saw another one on this 17 year old
teenager susan's parents were being born
white anthony dwight 17 claims he has
suffered his whole life from the shame
of being born white when i was a kid i'd
spend hours in the shower trying to wash
off my white skin but it would never go
away isn't there enough white people on
this planet haven't we
inflicted enough suffering racism and
depression in this world the young man's
lawyer robert huffman claims his client
has suffered severe psychological
distress symptoms of depression and
suicidal
tendencies because of what he calls the
burden of being white privileged because
a level of psychological distress on my
client we ask that his parents pay for
all the necessary expenses to change his
racial status including skin coloring
treatment
how to help okay first off that lawyer
needs to be disbarred immediately the
the lawyer that picks up yes i'm gonna
sue your parents for your skin color
that lawyer needs to be mocked into
oblivion putting aside the rest of this
ridiculous story obviously
but you see what they did
congratulations you made some 17 year
old kid he was just a kid
congratulations he hates himself this is
it any way you cut it whether it was a
black kid an asian kid a white kid
native american kid a jewish kid yep
like it's just sad any way you cut it so
but but the question becomes the
following how did this kid come to that
conclusion okay who reaffirmed something
to him over it's definitely not his
parents who reaffirmed and caused that
hate to him the entire machine so why is
this white bad you bad quite bad but you
better but all of a sudden let's
actually speculate let's actually
speculate do you think this 17 year old
kid is watching msnbc or cnn or fox no
okay so do you think this would have
been from one of his classmates
do you think this could have been from
one of the teachers or people
okay so he was the same this uh st louis
i think so but the point is somebody put
that thought in this kid's head period
somebody put that thought in this kid's
head and he has to kind of live up by
that my biggest concern with what's
going on with kids i said this the other
day is i'm not worried about me i'm
going to be able to afford to do
homeschooling or hire the best teachers
to teach my kids at my house and hey
just come down we'll hire three four
teachers every guy just come and rotate
we'll pay a hundred bucks an hour come
and do it but forget about me i've
busted the last 20 years to be in this
situation so if things got really
ridiculous i can at least be able to
influence my kids properly by hiring the
right teachers how about the other 98
percent of america that 95 of america
that can't afford to send their kids to
private school that they have to
leverage and just lean on public schools
that they can't change zoning they don't
have a choice
they have to go through the only choice
they have is either doing homeschooling
or try to control as much as possible um
which by the way it was crazy who was it
we had on that said the need for church
has increased oh yesterday i got this
random call did i tell you about that
yeah i told you about this random call i
got yesterday i'm at the baseball field
with dylan
this i get this call from illinois i'm
like who is this and you know my phone's
not saved the number so i pick it up is
this the one i saw you at the guard gate
no no no that's that's a prank i was
pulling on you that's a different one we
pulled a very good prank
on him and it has to do with something
it has to do with you i'll tell that
story in a minute but this guy calls me
so i call back
is this patrick
who's calling oh the one word yeah is
this patrick
i'm sorry who's colin it is patrick okay
patrick i said who's colin i can't tell
you my name because i don't want you to
ever talk about this on your podcast but
i watch all your stuff so the reason why
i'm calling me is because the interview
i watch with jack barsky
and i'm like jack barski kgb yes
and he says what is the difference
between the old testament and the new
testament
i said what's the context behind this
question he says what is the difference
between an old it's one word what is the
difference between old testament
newtonism i'm like
old testament you believe in that jewish
new testament christian no it's one word
i said are you saying jesus
bingo is jesus
i said what does kgb jack barsky have to
do with jesus
so he goes for 15 minutes i'm sitting
i'm like i can't even believe i'm
entertaining this conversation how'd you
get my phone the whole premise of his
call to say that america needs god today
that was his whole premise and by the
way
we hung up we had a great conversation
said i love you i follow him just don't
give my name don't give mine i'm like
i'm not going to give you your number on
a live podcast he says i'm still not
going to give you money i'm totally fine
now joel osteen if you're supposed to be
a five-year-old man by the way 65 year
old man 65 reminds us i don't want to
have because i don't want to get
persecution i said aren't you just as
guilty to be embarrassed to talk about
god as you are judging others who are
doing this i'm sorry you are just as
guilty because if you're so proud of the
belief on what's god done for you why
don't you be publicly talking about it
why are you being a closet christian
come out and talk about well that's a
fair assessment but nowadays at my job i
can be persecuted i can lose my job
bingo so look at the fears you feed it
people have right look at what's going
on but again i said this two podcasts
could go i'm saying that again today
if you're raising a kid today
everything becomes an insurance policy
okay
it's almost like okay
i'm gonna lean on sports to get my kids
as a positive distraction because a good
positive distraction is gonna get them
away from the other stuff a good private
school good friends
you know good uncles to have around i
need to kind of rely on a local church
that i trust to have the right values
and principles all you're looking at is
putting that right defense around you
and the right values to be taught and i
actually in a weird way this is going to
sound crazy every every we know
talking about religion is not something
we talk about on our podcast
i think in the craziest way
i think the next 10 to 20 years churches
are going to blow up i don't know why i
think church is going to blow up the
next 10 to 20 years oh i'll tell you why
yeah well first of all well first i just
want to say the craziest part of that
story that you just told is that you
pick up numbers that you don't recognize
is the most insane if i get a call
my phone number has been leaked so many
times and i've changed my phone
zero percent chance of picking up that
genuine yes is this patrick how could i
what like that is the most crazy thing i
have ever heard i can only imagine how
to make you crazier yeah i'll make you
crazier i've not changed my number in 20
years
i'm telling you it's been my number for
20 years if someone just comes knocking
on your door they just knock come on in
come on you seem like a guy i'd like to
talk to you about god come on in
in the craziest way in the craziest
thing this is going to sound crazy
i i so love a good debate
and a good discourse wow you're living
your best life
living in my best life how you enjoy
your girls someone's phone number you
recognize like uh first of all don't you
don't recognize that watch me get 50
calls today
i'm not picking up today's call that's
also that's so f it shows you how we're
all wired differently because so right
we do a very similar thing for a living
right so i run businesses outside but i
talk for a living so we do basically the
same thing i talk into so i wake up at 6
a.m and i'm basically talking till till
whatever day whatever time that shuts
down so it could be 8 p.m i've talked
all day when when i'm done i almost to
the point that i cannot speak i turn on
seinfeld and i'm like that's it don't
talk to me but you what you just said
there is you love it so much i just do
and i don't think it's that you love it
more than me it's that we're wired
probably a little bit differently that
if i got a call from an anonymous number
at eight o'clock that would be the devil
to me and you're like yes let's continue
the conversation don't wait to talk to
this random person i mean that is
absolutely
by the way i'll give you one thing that
it's even funnier than this so when i
get random texts from people and i don't
recognize the number here's what i'll do
did you see what i did the other day
with the guy let me see can you call
that no no no let me tell you what i do
with them because them i have fun with
so guy texts me says uh hey uh uh uh are
we gonna be able to see you later on
today and i texted this guy back no joke
you should see this i should show this
guy's number and put it on the screen i
respond back i said um did kamala tell
you i won't be making it
so the guy's like excuse me i said yeah
just tell kamala i can't make it because
joe will be upset but kamala knows what
i'm going through right now and then he
responds back saying i'm just a
valuetainer man are you really talking
to kamala harris and i just leave the
text alone i don't respond back i wonder
what this guy is probably thinking about
saying pat's talking to kamalaires
they're going to party but anyways going
back to to yes the point you're gonna
make i think you're completely right i
think church
i'm actually i'm partly making this
argument in my book that because the
woke thing is so out of control and
because two plus two is five and boys
are girls and if you're not racist you
are racist because everything is so
backwards when everything's backwards
people need something to fall back on
and i i can feel this i can feel it i
mean i thought i was an atheist five or
six years ago i'm not anymore i'm a
believer i toured with jordan peterson
he moved me on some on probably the most
important question of of all you know in
essence um i think a lot of people are
going to go that direction it's a sad
state in a way because
because liberalism in its truest form
should be able to stand on its own but
but the left has destroyed liberalism
change things so that words have no
meaning anymore and then people will go
to religion i'm actually not saying that
religion is bad i i'm not saying that at
all actually i think at the end
societies somehow need an organizing
principle and i don't know that there is
one
better than belief at some level uh but
i i completely agree with you are you
you're jewish you go to temples where do
you go um you know it's funny i i've
sort of come back towards it dennis
prager actually helped me a lot on this
he ran in la
he he's not a rabbi technically but he
was running services and runs sort of
like a it's sort of like a misfit temple
and i started going and i you know i
dennis has been a mentor and a friend
and everything else and he brought me
back to a lot of that but you know for
jews i'm sure it's somewhat similar to
you
it's become more of a culture and a way
of thinking and a sense of humor and
holy [ __ ] we survived somehow five
thousand years of this lunacy and
there's still a couple of us left
so but i am trying to figure out how
that piece is into my life well
regarding regarding church religion
ultimately what we're talking about i
think is just a bigger sense of purpose
and meaning in life
ultimately we're all just trying to
figure out what the hell are we doing
here like how what is life what is the
meaning of life
and
i mean look at the stats the most common
religion now is
non-believer yeah right so
god has been taken out of society and
i'm not religious but i i will say that
i do
and this might just because of my
upbringing and my mom you could do
whatever you want to do and yeah
affirmation and like a typical jewish
mom
but
for most people in america they don't
have necessarily a higher sense of
purpose or meaning and cova has
exacerbated that you're stuck at home
alone you lost your job you don't know
what's going on you're taking opioids
you're you're looking at everyone on tv
and on social media everyone's doing
amazing and you're just stuck in this
you know shitty life and if you're if
there's nothing to cling on to for
religion what do you have and a lot of
people cling on to politics you know
especially even on the left these days
but that's true that's why you have to
give the woke credit because they turned
a political ideology into a cult
you cannot get out of that cult it's why
so many of them go so crazy why is jon
stewart right now
screaming about white people all the
time it's because he went into the woke
thing and then once you're in it jon
stewart knows he's a hundred million
dollar white guy middle-aged white guy
in essence right so he has to keep going
otherwise they'll turn on him too
it's a religion that you cannot leave
and he's what you would call and i
learned this term literally from you
david a classic liberal he he should be
truly i don't think he's in his true
head i don't think he's a crazy woke
leftist right but just you know i don't
know that anyone's watching he's gone
down that path yeah doing bill maher
avoided that and stayed true to himself
i mean i do this on my show all the time
i'm so frustrated with bill maher i
really am yeah i'm supposed to be why
are you podcasting
because he's so freaking close he's so
damn close to getting it and then he
just shoots himself in the foot yes so
so bill maher he gets it on critical
race theory now he got it on covid
finally two years too late but he got it
he gets it on the gender stuff he gets
it on free speech he gets all the big
ones
but until you're willing to say i will
not support and vote for people who have
ushered this all in
then you're then at some point you're no
longer doing a service right right it's
one thing to wake so you asked me before
where we started was about waking people
up and how do we move people well bill
maher i guess at some level he's woken
up some liberals right so that that is
good and by the way this is a guy who
i've loved and admired for for 20 years
but at the end
because of trump derangement syndrome
and his bingo by the way trump broke him
to the point that you can't you can't
say i'm against critical race there i'm
against all the gender stuff and then
it's like all right bill so when it came
down to it would you have voted for
glenn younkin or not and if the answer
is no you would have voted for terry
mcauliffe then you actually aren't at
the end of the road yet so he's getting
people almost to the promised land and
right when they get to the promised land
they're right there the border he then
takes them the other way so last week
you probably saw it he sat on a show he
said that the republicans would love if
there were no black supreme court
justices
uh you know there is a black supreme
court justice and he's a conservative
did you know that bill and everyone
loves him and i guarantee you and i yeah
he's an uncle tom and i guarantee you
that every conservative in the country
would love if there were 12 of him so at
the end
you get there and then all you got left
is but their race i think his problem
actually is that he's called so many
religious people crazy for 20 years
it's very hard for him to put that
together special called religious it's
not like yeah
but let me tell you exactly what's
happening with him yeah because i'm
living it yeah i got it he's going down
the road he's going to the path you said
he gets to the pearly gates and who's at
the gate bro it's trump that's
ultimately what's happening is you get
to the gate
and you're like hold on everything was
made so much sense and trump's at the
gate and this is why i think
the republicans will be shooting
themselves in the foot having trump come
back versus a desantis i think no matter
who desantis runs against landslide
if trump runs
anyone's guess i think tyler's got
someone to tell us go ahead tyler well
you're just talking about the black
supreme court justice uh clarence thomas
let's not forget that george bush
nominated janice rogers the first black
woman to the supreme court and who shot
it down oh there was a guy a friend
ladies and gentlemen
he's very confused yeah what's that
guy's name excuse me
we all live in the present and we don't
even open a history book who the hell is
thurgood marshall and who got him onto
the court and who didn't want him on the
court nobody wants to go back and look
at that nobody wants to go back and and
look at what was the real party of civil
rights why was the republican party
founded exactly
you know and people forget oh it'd be
the first
thurgood marshall i recall was an
amazing intellect he was amazing jurist
not because he was black because he was
an amazing jurist
and you'll look at how he ended up on
the court and all we'll look back and we
only want to put it in today's time
because they need it okay so check this
out we don't have the j we don't have
education we have agendication hold on
are you getting another call from an
anonymous
by the way
seriously somebody just text me from a
number i don't recognize saying patrick
great show i said tell kamala i said
hello
bye-bye here you go how the hell did you
get my number but anyway so here we go
a highly educated white military
president dwight david eisenhower
sends 101st airborne in to protect nine
people who had the right to go to the
high school that was in their
neighborhood not be bused across town if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]